[MUSIC PLAYING]
COLTON OGDEN: All right.
Good afternoon, everybody.
Thank you so much for
coming to today's talk.
My name is Colton Ogden.
I'm the course instructor
for GD50, which
is CS50's new Introduction
to Game Development course.
We started this last spring and
we've been having lectures every week
so far for the last semester.
Last week we took a
look at Portal, which
is a famous game by Valve, whereby
you get a gun that can essentially
shoot these portals that
defy the laws of space
onto different services in the game.
Walk in and out of them and teleport
through them and see through them.
And there are a host of
interesting challenges associated
with implementing a game like this.
Now last week we looked at a
simple version of it in Unity,
but today we are joined by Dave Kircher
and Tejeev Kohli of Valve Software who
actually were on the
Portal team and implemented
all of the interesting sort of
design and technical decisions
that went about making it work
and making it fun and believable.
So without any further ado,
this is the "Portal Problems."
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
TEJEEV KOHLI: Hi.
So we're just going to run through.
Both me and Dave were actually
students when we were hired by Valve,
and we were hired to recreate the work
we did as a student project for Valve
for Portal 1 and for Portal 2.
And today we just wanted
to talk to you about some
of the issues we had trying to
create the mechanic for portals,
and then also some of the design, both
the technical and some of the design
issues that we had to tackle and work
on to make the mechanic work properly.
So Dave is going to start off
and then I'll jump in later.
DAVE KIRCHER: Hey, folks.
As he mentioned, my name
is Dave Kircher I was hired
on specifically to work for Portal.
So I'm going to go ahead and preface.
We're jumping through a lot of topics
today and jumping very quickly,
so this is a very video
heavy presentation
so that we can jump quickly in and out.
And I'm sorry if I go a little too fast.
I'm kind of optimizing for the stream.
So hopefully, if I have gone
too quickly over something,
you can review the stream
and see it a second time.
So without further ado, let's
start off-- just quickly.
I'm assuming that most
of the people here
have played Portal or at least are
familiar with it in some sense.
That's just an assumption.
And that, for at least
the technical portions,
that you are at least somewhat
familiarized with 3D rendering.
If you're not, you may need to study
up a little bit and then come back.
But let's start off with
just what is a portal?
A portal is a discontinuity in 3D space.
It's a 2D discontinuity
where we basically
define a 2D rectangle somewhere in
space such that the front face-- sorry,
the back face of the 2D rectangle is
defined as the front face of another 2D
rectangle.
So I've got my simple little
example here of this blue portal
and this orange portal.
We're defining them to be back to back,
which gets us this result over here.
So from the perspective
of this little portal guy,
it should look like there's another
room attached with a cube in it.
But we're not actually
moving 3D space at all
because otherwise we're trying to
make sure that this perspective is
true for both this guy and the cube.
And then you'd have this
weird overlapping space
that doesn't make any sense to anybody.
So we do a lot of hacks
to make it seem like space
is folding in these interesting
ways without actually moving space.
Another way to think of
it is that it's a door.
If you look closely at this
doorway, it's a very standard door.
It's a door like you walk through
it, different stuff happens.
But what I'm not telling you initially
is that this actually isn't a door.
For technical reasons, this
level required a portal here
because we needed this room to move.
So even though it looks like a
doorway, it's completely fake.
And that it's a doorway
that actually takes you
about a half mile across the level.
But it looks like a door, and
so my job on the Portal series
was to make sure that when
we're creating portals that they
feel to the player like a doorway.
And if you think of them
in terms of a doorway,
all the interesting stuff for a portal
happens on the inside of the doorway
and nothing interesting
happens on the outside.
And it's my job to make sure that
all the interesting things that
are happening outside
the door don't happen.
Because that's all stuff
that doesn't make any sense.
So as you can see, I just
flew across the level.
And that's the other side of
that door that we just looked at.
And I'm walking through
it and it's a doorway.
So it's a door that doesn't
take you a couple of inches.
It takes you about a half
mile across the level.
Now we're into our
rendering section, which
is basically one of my main
expertises in the portal area.
So we're going be talking
about quite a few things
and I'm going to jump in
quickly, so hopefully I
don't spew it out too quickly.
That's kind of my problem.
So there are primarily two layers
to render a portal of view.
There might be more, but these are the
two that I am primarily familiar with.
The preliminary way that we did
it with Narbacular Drop, which
was the predecessor to Portal
was with rendered texture.
And then when we got to working
on the Portal franchise,
we switched to a method
where you draw it
all in a single pass using
what's known as a stencil buffer
and I'll be talking more
about that in a bit.
But there are tradeoffs to each method.
So with a texture, you have to have
separate textures per portal view.
And if you have support
for recursion, you
have to have many, many textures
pre-allocated to do this.
So your memory growth
gets big very fast.
You have to use the Painter's
Algorithm or something like it
to render your portals.
You basically have to figure
out the deepest portal you
can see into and render that one first.
And then any outward
ones from that you're
going to render them
because they're going
to contain a view of that first portal.
So you have to render it in that order.
And I don't know if it's true anymore.
It definitely was when I originally
was working on the first portal.
That you couldn't effectively
use anti-aliasing,
so you get small visual artifacts
as you get close to a portal
because it would be rendered
as a texture that doesn't quite
render the same way as the
rest of the back buffer.
But it is the simplest
to implement, especially
if you don't support recursion at all.
It is super simple to do because you
can ignore the Painter's Algorithm
and just render all of them
before you of your main view.
By contrast, when you
render with stencils,
it renders the entire
frame to the back buffer
so you don't have any extra
texture memory requirements.
You're doing it all in a single pass.
You're starting from your main
view and working your way in.
You actually have to nest it a
little bit, so it's interesting.
You are guaranteed to get
homogeneous visual quality
because it's a single pass.
The way you're rendering
the rest of your frame.
But it has a lot of extra
complexity of when you render them
and how you render them.
So this rendering portion
is going to require
quite a bit of spatial thinking.
So I'm going to show you this video.
Basically this is a layout I'm
going to use a couple of times.
Does this play?
Hopefully-- yes, OK.
This is a room layout that I'm
going to use a couple of times
where I've got an orange
portal and a blue portal.
And behind each one is a thin
wall with some stuff behind it.
But hopefully to help illustrate
what's in front of the blue portal,
you can see there's a whole
bunch of blue stuff over there.
So yes, that is the example layout I
want you to kind of keep in your head
because spatial thinking is
important to actually have reference.
Let this finish one more time.
OK.
Now this is something that pertains
to both rendering with textures
and stencils and I'm going
to let this play once
because I was advised that if
I front load this too much,
it sounds confusing.
So while I'm playing this, I
want you to look at the fact
that when the orange portal is
on screen and when it's not,
everything inside where
the orange oval is
looks exactly the same for when
it is and when it is not there.
And so what I'm doing here is as
I'm toggling between the views
is I am teleporting to
where the virtual camera is.
That's rendering out
of the orange portal.
Whoops-- come on, go back.
Oh, God.
OK.
I'm toggling back and forth.
I'm looking into the
orange portal, but I'm
toggling to where the virtual
camera is behind the blue portal.
So if you remember back
to when I said that we're
defining the back face
of one rectangle to be
the front face of
another rectangle, that
means that they should
be coplanar at all times.
And so if you think of
my player model in terms
of walking it to the orange portal.
When I'm rendering my exit view, I
should end up behind the blue portal
as I'm rendering out of it.
So it's important to remember that
all the angles carry over from that.
And most importantly that whether
you're rendering textures or rendering
to stencil that nothing
inside ever moves
because it should be the
exact same view angles,
the pixels should be in
the exact same place.
If they're not in the same
place, your math is wrong.
And this is especially important
when rendering with textures
because one of the first mistakes
I've seen several people do
is that they render the
entire screen to a texture.
And then they map the entire texture
to this little quadratic here
and it looks all weird depending
on how close or far away you are.
But as long as you project the--
sorry.
Trying to work with
videos is not the easiest.
So as long as you project
where the vertices of your mesh
are in screen space, you can reuse those
coordinates as your texture coordinates
and then it will line up perfectly.
So that's the point of why
it's rendering as one-to-one.
You just want to make sure that
you're rendering the same parts
to the same part of the screen.
Now I said I'd be using
that previous layout a bunch
and I swear I'm going
to get back to there.
But this is a much better layout
for rendering with stencils,
and so now you need to learn a
new layout just for a minute.
It's only used in stencils.
But I've got these two
portals looking at each other.
They're kind of-- one
stacked on top of the other,
and they've got these
light bridges that are just
serving to show you that transparencies
are kind of a special case.
So I'm going to play it one more time.
So you just got two
portals facing each other.
And even though they're tiny, it
does make an infinite recursion down
into the portals.
So rendering with stencils.
I'm kind of assuming that
for this part of the talk
that you have some idea
what a depth buffer is.
You may need to read up
on that if you don't.
The stencil buffer is very
similar to the depth buffer
in that it defines rules and operations
for when we can wholesale just not
draw a pixel or when
we do want to draw it.
And then also while
we are drawing pixels,
you can define several operations
of how to modify the depth buffer.
But for all intents and purposes,
it's invisible to the user
except for the end result. So stencil
buffer, a lot like a depth buffer,
but you're controlling the values
in code instead of by vertex depth.
So before we render any scene using
stencils, what we're going to do
is we're going to clear our
stencil buffer at the same time
as we clear our depth buffer.
We're going to clear
it to all zero values.
And the stencil buffer we were
working with with Portal 1--
I believe it only had two bits.
I could be wrong.
It might be up to eight bits,
but it's not a lot of bits.
So we need to be very conservative
with the values we put in there.
So we're going to clear it to zero.
So everything in it is zero.
And then we're going to render all
of the OPEC objects in our scene
and that's where we get to the
visual I'm showing you here.
So you'll notice that none of
the light bridges are here.
None of the cool fancy
window stuff is here.
So all we've done is draw
in all the opaque objects.
And then we take a special
detour to render a portal.
At this point, we've
rendered this oval here.
And while we're rendering the
oval, we tell the rendering system
to increment the stencil buffer
wherever we render a pixel.
So while we're rendering, all of
the pixels here go from 0 to 1
and that's an important bit.
So we're going to be able to
use that to tell the depth--
to tell draw operations
where to draw from then on.
And then as soon as we've drawn the
incrementing of the stencil buffer,
we tell all draw operations
from then on to only draw
where the stencil value is 1.
And we tell it to not modify anything.
We're only drawing where there's a 1.
And then we can basically just
forget all about stencil buffers
for a little bit and keep drawing.
But at this point if you've been
following along with the depth buffer,
we've already drawn this nice
little wall behind the portal.
So the depth is the same
as this little quad here.
And so the first thing we do is we
render a full screen quad with depth
at maximum value, which
does really effectively
make this a hole at this point.
And if we were to continue drawing
opaque objects and things like that,
they would just show up in this hole.
So then we start--
after we have drawn, after we
have punched our hole in depth
and we've required that all draw
operations have this matching
stencil value of 1, then what we do is
we just start over in our main scene
again and just draw it again.
But this time we move
our virtual camera.
Just the same operation as I
showed you in the rendering.
It's one-to-one, we just have
to do a matrix transform such
that we're behind the blue
portal and we draw it again.
And so, let's see here.
I think I have a magnifying glass.
So you may notice that we're in--
whoops.
OK, I can't apparently zoom
and use a laser pointer.
So you may notice that
the player model is there,
and then the exact same setup
as I had shown you before.
It's the same set of
quads and the oval again.
And we do the exact same thing again.
We tell it to increment so all the
values in this tiny little oval
here are now 2.
And then at that point we tell, OK, only
render pixels with a stencil value of 2
and then we can just ignore
stencil buffers again.
We punch the hole again,
and then we recurse again.
And we go into a value of 3.
At this point--
I'm going to get more
into detail on it later,
but we stop recursively
rendering to stencil buffers
because otherwise we'd draw
a whole bunch of scenes
that we're not going to actually see.
We pull a little trick
that I'm going to get into.
So as we've drawn all of our opaques,
we would theoretically do our detour.
We don't.
And then we finish by drawing
all of our translucent objects.
And I know it's very
tiny to see them there,
but it will become more apparent later.
I think that-- sorry, that's
actually our rendering trick.
And there, now we've actually drawn
the translucence in that view.
And I know this is very small, but it'll
make more sense at recursion level 1.
So as we draw our
translucent objects, we're
still all confined to drawing
where stencil value is 2.
And then once we are done drawing
all of our translucent objects,
we render the portal oval--
whoops, sorry, sorry.
I'm going to pretend that
we're drawing to the big oval
here because it's easier to see.
We would draw another quad at
this level, sort of like a window,
telling it to decrement the
stencil value back to 1.
I'm sorry, I need to take a step back.
We need to replace depth so that
there's no longer a hole there.
So we draw the full screen quad
with depth equal to the portal plane
while still restricting to the
nested view and then we decrement.
Sorry.
So by the time we've
done decrementing, that
means all of these pixels inside
this first recursion are now 1 again.
Every single one of them is
a 1 on the stencil value.
So we can continue rendering the
translucence from the first recursion
just like we did when
we're doing the opaques.
We can say just restrict your
drawing to all stencil value 1.
And then we finish our
translucence there.
We do the exact same thing again while
we're going back to the main view.
We fix up our depth and then we
decrement the stencil values again.
And then we just finish
out our main scene,
and now you have portals
drawn using stencils.
They required no extra
texture memory whatsoever.
So bouncing back to
the scene that we had
shown before this, one of the things
that we had to solve pretty quickly
is when you have some object
in the middle of a portal,
you have to be able to see
it in two places at once.
And the way that we do this
is we literally just look up
every piece and rendering geometry.
It uses every texture and replicate
it and teleport it every single frame
to wherever the original is.
And while we're replicating,
this object over here.
You can see that it's slightly
more in front of the orange portal.
So basically the rules are defined
such that whichever object--
whichever side of the object has
its origin in front of the portal
is the master.
And the origin for this
cube is right in its middle,
and origin is just a term that we use
to define the one point in space that
defines where this object is.
So usually it's in the
center of an object.
Not always, but that means
this is the real one.
And this is our complete
and utter fake one
that we have to do for every single
object that is penetrating the portal.
Now when we duplicate
geometry and whether we
not-- whether we duplicate or not,
we have another problem to solve.
I'm going to let this video play.
I'm going to be toggling
a broken part on and off.
So when the cube is not behind the
wall, that's the fixed version.
And when you can see it behind the
wall, that's the broken version.
So if you think about
replicating geometry,
we have replicated the entire
model to this orange portal.
Which means all the
stuff that is supposed
to be in front of the blue portal
is also sticking behind this wall.
Because once again, we have defined
the two faces to be coplanar.
So what we have to do is we have
to use what's known as a clip plane
to tell the rendering
system, you know what?
Just don't draw any pixels if the mesh
is on this half of this half space.
And we define the half space
to be the portal plane.
And we can turn this
clip plane on and off
as we're drawing objects
inside the portal plane
and that's what makes it work.
Otherwise it would clip the whole world.
I'm going to play the video again.
It happens.
So, yeah, we're just
telling it, hey, you
need to just ignore every single pixel
that's on that half of all of space.
Don't draw them.
And that makes it so it
doesn't seem like it's
sticking out the back in weird
ways that people don't understand.
OK, now this is a very similar concept.
Something that we coined
the term "banana juice" for.
Even back in Narbacular Drop
because it's just confusing.
And I know you're asking yourself,
what in the heck is "banana juice?"
That doesn't make any sense.
So we decided to use a
completely insane term for it.
Because even our technical
shorthand for describing the problem
didn't accurately describe what it was.
So we decided to use a term that--
it was obvious that
explanation was needed.
So what we've got here is
I've got my orange camera
and I'm looking into
the orange portal here.
And that means I've got my blue
camera, virtual camera here,
looking out of the blue portal.
And if you remember back
to my example, we've
got this geometry that's
behind the blue portal.
And it's between the blue
virtual camera and the portal,
and if we render that, it's
going to look completely broken.
So "banana juice" is a term
to define this broken stuff
that you would see if you were
looking behind the thin wall.
And I have a video of it here.
I believe I'm toggling back and
forth between views just like when
I showed you rendering as one-to-one.
And that's me turning
off the clip plane.
This is what it would look like if we
were in the virtual space and the clip
planes were not enabled and
then I go back to our main view.
And you'll see as I move around in a
second that it looks completely broken
and it kind of breaks your brain if
you don't understand what's going on.
So that is "banana juice," and
you fix it exactly the same way
as with the entity clipping.
You have clip models, but what we do
is I'm going to replay the video here.
If you're watching, this entire
part of the level is now clipped.
So what we do is while we're
rendering a virtual camera,
we just clip the entire world
behind the portal plane.
All of it.
Everything that's back there.
So that's how you fix
"banana juice" too.
It's not super difficult
once you understand it,
but I can tell you it
took me about two days
to figure out exactly what was
going on when I originally saw it.
It just didn't make any sense.
So moving on again, I know we're
jumping a lot and I'm sorry.
We're just going to keep
moving on at a quick pace.
So infinite recursion is something
that people kind of expected
to see when they were playing portal.
If you ever played the
original Narbacular Drop,
we didn't support any form of
recursion and it was kind of a letdown.
So I'm going to go into how this works.
So in this view, you can see
that we have this blue portal.
That's our first recursion right here
and it's taking up most of the screen.
And then we've got this blue portal
that you can see the entirety of it.
That's our second recursion.
And this one in here is
completely and totally fake.
So that one, there is no
portal there whatsoever.
What we're doing is we're
taking whatever we see
of this portal, the second recursion.
We're taking that exact view
from the previous frame.
We're taking those pixels and then
we're basically doing a fix up
in case you moved your camera around.
And we're applying the texture
coordinates from the second portal
to where the third portal would be.
And by a completely fake, I mean we
didn't even render this blue oval.
That's just a copy of
this oval right here.
So it's the exact same thing as if you
point a video camera at a video monitor
that's showing what it's recording.
You get that feedback loop.
But we have access to a little
bit of extra special math.
That means that we don't
get that weird snaking
effect if you move it back and forth.
We can fix it up quickly.
But this video is actually going to show
you about how this quickly breaks down.
Because if you're
thinking ahead, you might
be wondering what happens if you
can't see all the second portal.
And the answer is that we stretch it.
So as you watch the third one, it just
kind of stretches off in weird ways.
Which is a problem that, if
we spend a bunch of time,
we probably could have fixed.
But in game development, sometimes
you just call it good enough
and move on because I bet anybody
that played the original Portal never
noticed this whatsoever.
[LAUGHING]
So another breakdown of it, which I
find personally annoying and interesting
at the same time.
I'm just going to show
the video of it first.
As I'm walking, you'll notice at the
third recursion, which is completely
fake, you're going to see a pop.
You're going to see every single time I
walk through a portal, it pops around.
So this is actually fairly easy
to explain once you understand--
really understand how the hack works.
So if you look at my
visualization here, this
is what the actual recursion would
look like if we actually did it.
So we've got a couple of portals
here at these blue lines.
And so inside our first portal
that we're fairly close to,
our field of view is really wide.
And then as we get to our second portal,
it gets really narrow really fast.
But then as we get to the
third, it narrows even more.
And then the fourth,
it narrows even more.
But since we're cutting and
pasting, the second recursion,
if you look down here on this
visualization, this is the hack.
So we take this one, the
second visualization, and copy
and paste it onto the
third and onto the fourth.
And you can notice that this
doesn't converge at all.
It doesn't narrow.
So we're seeing the same
amount of wall around each
of the recursions no matter what, no
matter how narrow this magenta cone is.
So as we walk through a
portal, the magenta cone,
we're picking a portal that's
further off because now
that's the second recursion
after we walk through a portal.
So it starts off narrow,
which is closer to what
it should look like at infinity.
It should narrow to basically
where you're seeing a blue tube.
But then as we walk closer
and closer to the main portal,
then it's going to widen
and widen and widen.
And so there's just a pop
where it snaps into place.
So hopefully that made sense.
And once again, completely
changing topics because we
got so many things to cover.
So when we're rendering
portals, we have to have
a mix of rendering first
person and third person.
So in this case, you can see I've
got my third-person model over here
through this portal.
Another third person model over here.
And then we don't see it in the main
view because I'm about to turn it on.
It would look really weird if you saw
the third-person view in the main view.
Yeah.
I mean, some games do try to fix this
with very special representations.
They'll try to draw just the
legs or something like that.
But, yes, so we have to
have a complicated system
to figure out when to draw third
person and when to draw first person.
And if you were to guess, I
bet you would say, well, just
render a third person every
time you look through a portal.
And it turns out it's slightly
more complicated than that.
I'm not actually going to get
into the complicated version,
but I'm going to show
you how it's broken
if you use that simple rule
because why would life be easy
and we would just be
able to render just when
we're on the other side of a portal.
So in this case--
let me look up.
So you'll notice in this
case, I'm on a tilted angle.
And this is a case where my feet
are on one side of the portal
and my eyes are on the
other side of the portal.
So it kind of breaks
the original system that
would say, oh, just render if you're
on the other side of a portal.
And so, yeah, it's a
little more complicated.
Not terribly.
It should actually look
way more broken than this,
but we actually had the
fix in several places.
And this is a special build where
I had to go back and break things
and only broken it in one place.
Yeah, OK.
And then the last on
our rendering portion.
So earlier I had talked about
how we need to duplicate
geometry that is mid-portal.
But there's also another thing
that we need to duplicate,
which there are screen space
affects where we can query
draw operations and things like that.
And so one way that we use these draw
operations that are in screen space
is to determine how much light
glare to use around these lights.
And so how these work are
basically we draw a quad
while we're drawing the light.
And then we say, OK,
in a couple of frames
I want you to tell me how
many pixels actually drew.
And we're not allowed to actually query
this immediately because of pipeline
reasons.
We don't have the results
for several frames.
So we have to cache off
that handle that says
how many pixels did you draw and we'll
get the result at some point later.
Sometimes you're lucky and it's
just one frame, but usually two
or three frames-- you have
to save it for a while.
But you may notice that
even though we're not
replicating the geometry of the
light, we're drawing two of them
because they're in screen space.
So that means that this query
system had to be smart about it
and I'm going to show how we
have two separate results.
Now if we had used the engine
as it was originally written,
there would be just one
query for one light.
But then that would mean that
these lights would dim in unison.
So we need to have separate
buckets for each view of portals.
And every view query that portal--
any view query that is issued
while in that recursion,
we have to keep it in a totally
separate bucket and call it back later.
And then as we walk through portals,
we have to transfer those buckets.
So if I were to walk into the blue
portal at this point, all of those
handles we have to
transfer to the main view.
And then all the ones that are from the
main view we transfer into what was now
orange because we would be
walking out of this orange one
if we walked into the blue.
So, yeah, that is the quick set of
rendering things I wanted to cover.
So now I'm going to hand it
off to my colleague, Tejeev,
to talk a bit about design.
Give your spatial
thinking a bit of a rest.
[CHUCKLES]
TEJEEV KOHLI: So that was
a lot of technical stuff
about rendering of portals.
And you can see it's more
complex than it seems at first.
The naive solution seems like we'll
get you most of the way there,
but then as you start putting in
more things in the game and more ways
to play a game, to
interact with the game,
you see there's a bunch
of different complexities
that you have to account for.
And a lot of those complexities
are not just in a technical sense,
but also from a design sense.
So I just want to talk
through some of the issues
that we came up with as we were making
Portal 1 and 2 and some of the ways
we tried to solve them.
One of the first things
I wanted to mention
was when first coming up
with the idea for portals,
before figuring out if we
should spend a bunch of time
making this idea, this new game mechanic
that most people haven't seen before.
What we did was--
Dave and his team made
a prototype of Portal
in a 2D game engine that is used in
DigiPen while they were students.
And it was made in-house
DigiPen 2D engine.
And you can see here that
it's a 2D version of Portal,
but it's still got all the basic game
mechanics that are used in Portal.
And the main goal of doing something
like this is to vet out the mechanics
and see if they're
still fun at their core.
And part of what you do
here is you playtest, right?
You make this simple
prototype, and you get
other people to try it out and
play it and say, hey, is this fun?
Is this something that we should
spend our next year working on
as a proper 3D game?
And the prototype you can see had
most of the basic functionality
there and kind of vetted out the idea
of the mechanics to take it forward.
And as we take the
mechanics forward, one
of the first things
that you realize is this
is a brand new mechanic that
people don't really understand
and you have a train them.
Train them with how the
mechanic works and also
train them with sufficient
knowledge so they
can use that mechanic to solve
puzzles, which is the core of the game.
And one of the things
that we did is you have
to have certain sections
of the game where
you can be sure that the player has the
knowledge that they need to progress.
So a lot of this is about making
sure that the levels you're designing
are done in such a way that when
the player finishes that level,
they have that knowledge
that you want them to have.
And one of the ways we ensure that is
through doing a lot of play testing,
and play testing is something I'll talk
about a little more as the talk goes
on.
But the basic idea of
play testing is just
getting someone else to play the game.
And that someone else
could be a coworker
who sits next to you, your friend--
anyone else really.
Someone you get especially to come
play the game from outside the company,
but usually it's just your coworkers,
people that sit next to you.
People that see you work on the game but
don't know exactly what you're doing.
And you can observe them
and see what they're doing,
get some feedback from
them, and then use that data
and iterate on the mechanic.
And you can see here, this
was a level in Portal 1.
It was pretty early on, this level,
and you could see the portals here.
The blue portal here
is moving on a timer.
It moves from one to
the next to the next.
And the idea of this level was
by the time players solve this,
they understand that I go in one
portal and come out the other.
That's the basic idea here.
And in Portal 1, this level did a pretty
good job of teaching players that.
For Portal 2, we have
a very similar puzzle.
I'm going to just try and play here.
It's a pretty similar puzzle.
The idea is the same thing.
You have the three sections
that the portal can go.
The one change we made here was we
move the portal away from a timer
and moved it to a button.
So this way the player has more control
of where the portals are opening.
There are a few reasons for this.
The main one here is like the level in
Portal 2 has a lot more visual noise.
There's a lot more like--
it's an old level, a lot of
foliage, a lot of destroyed stuff.
So it's not as clean as Portal 1.
And also, there's a case
of Portal 2, there's
a lot of people that have
already played Portal 1
and are probably already
familiar with the mechanics.
So we don't want them to
have to go through the timers
and wait for all the things to happen,
even though they know how it works.
So this way they can
just go in and show us
that they know how the
portals work without having
to wait through all the timers.
And the basic goal is the same thing.
That by the end of this level, we're
confident that the players understand
how portals work.
One of the other things that
you learn through play testing
is you learn what you
need to teach the player.
There's sometimes when
you'll be making the game
and there's certain things that
you as a designer or as a creator
won't think are challenging
concepts or are things that need
to be talked to players explicitly.
One of those things
that we noticed early on
is this concept here where a lot
of players kind of thought portals
were one way.
That you go in one and you come
out the other and that's it.
But they have to be taught that
you can actually go in both ways.
You can go in the blue one
and come out the orange,
or you can go in the orange
one and come out the blue one.
And so this puzzle specifically
does that, where the blue one
is the only one that'd be moving.
The orange one stays stationary.
First you go in the blue one, you come
out the orange one, replace the blue,
and then you go in the orange
one and come out the blue one.
The idea with this again is you
have to figure through play testing
is how you figure out
the different things.
The different discrete small things
that you need to teach the player.
And also try to figure out
how to teach them in a way
where they're figuring it out
instead of you telling it to them.
So for the most part in
Portal 1 and 2, there's
certain things that we tell the player.
But for the most part we
want them to figure it
out and have that epiphany themselves.
Because then they really learn it.
If you just tell it to them, they
might not take in the exact knowledge.
Another thing here is this
was a level in Portal 2,
but we noticed through
one of our play tests--
I looked through a few of our
play tests that players were super
hesitant to place portals on the floor.
Even though this level is probably
the fifth or sixth one in the game,
and you've done that a few
times in the game before this.
But usually you are
doing it way down there
and doing a fling mechanic where you
fly through the portal and come out.
So players have placed
portal on the floor before,
but they haven't done
it right at their feet.
So we had to design a scenario
here where the only way forward--
you're trapped in this
black room with nothing else
and the only thing you can do is
place a portal on the floor there.
And that's one of the things that
you realize as you keep testing.
You'll come across players
of different skill levels
and different knowledge of video
games and different knowledge
of how controls work.
And typically you want to make
sure that you're not only catering
to the low end or the high end.
You want to make sure that both of them
can have a good time with your game.
So you want to design puzzle games
in a way that aren't super intrusive.
If a player that sees
this get here already
knows that I can place
portals on floor and go by.
This doesn't seem like
anything that's stopping him.
This just seems like part of the level.
But to a new player that
comes in here and is
like I don't know how to proceed, it
takes them a while to figure it out.
And then when they have that aha
moment, they feel pretty smart about it.
So you want to make sure
that you're designing stuff
in a way that isn't frustrating players
that already understand the mechanics,
but also isn't making players that
don't understand the mechanics have
to be super frustrated as well.
Another thing that we had to do--
Portal 1 and 2 both have this mechanic
where you go into a portal on the floor
and come out one on the wall and
it keeps your momentum and velocity
and flings you forward.
One of the things we noticed while
we were working on this mechanic
is that there's a lot of times when
players don't exactly quite line up
as they're falling through the portal.
Which means that when they fall
in, they're going to fall out--
they're not going to come out of the
portal on the wall in the correct way.
And a lot of times players won't know
that they had the right solution,
they just kind of messed up
the execution a little bit.
And we want to try and help
the players in these cases,
but again try to be
not intrusive about it.
Because you want to make
sure that the players--
as they're solving puzzles,
they're not thinking
that they had the right solution but it
didn't work the first time I tried it.
So now I have to rethink the whole
solution even though the solution was
correct the first time.
So one of the things we used--
we used a few different things
to help the players out in this way.
And again, with the idea of them
being mostly invisible to the player.
They're not always completely
invisible and in some cases
we have ways to opt out of them.
But this is one of the
things that we used.
So if you notice here,
the player's going
to drop through the orange portal.
But as you notice as I walk through--
walk forward here, I'm purposely
not going to fall exactly straight.
And one of the mechanics
we had in the game was--
it was pretty subtle there,
but I'm going to do it again.
You'll see I'm walking to the side
and the game kind of funnels you
into the portal.
So we had the special thing we
used in portals, for portals
that are on the floor facing mostly up.
Imagine there's a cone
coming out of the portal,
and if you're falling from
some height and if you're
within that cone and the cone--
it's not super wide.
It's pretty narrow.
If you're within that
cone, then we kind of
funnel you into the
center of the portal.
So that when you're
coming out of it, you're
going to be lined up perfectly with it.
And as you can see, the third time
I did it there, it didn't happen.
Because the way this
works is that it only
works if you're looking at a portal.
So it works the second
time, but the third time I'm
going to go mostly in the same
direction and it's not going to work.
So that's our way of trying to
make these things be non-intrusive.
To where if players don't expect to go
in that portal, it's not going to work.
But if the player is looking at a
portal and they expect to go in it,
we kind of nudge them
along a little bit.
And you can see it here,
and this is a second case
of the same thing where there's a
portal on the floor and the ceiling.
And you can see as
the funnel is working,
the play is perfectly
in the center of it.
But I'm going to look forward a
little bit and disable the funnel.
And you can see the player's
going to go off axis
because the funnels are disabled and
the player slowly went out of it.
Yeah, the funnel is disabled now.
And again, the idea of this is to
reduce a bunch of the player frustration
and to reduce a bunch of the
false negatives that players get.
You want to make sure that players
that think they've got the solution,
and if it was the correct
solution, you want
to kind of help them out a little bit.
You don't to solve the puzzle for them.
You don't want to give them,
like, here's the answer.
But you do want to try and
help them out a little bit
because that helps that makes
the game a little bit more fun
and reduces the frustration.
So that was the help that we had
for when you're entering portals.
We also have the opposite and
that was there in Portal 1.
And in Portal 2, we
introduced something that
was the opposite of a helper, which we
used when you're coming out of portals.
So Portal 2 had this mechanic
called Aerial Faith Plates,
which is pretty straightforward.
You step on this faith plate
and it propels you to the air.
And the level designers can
place the faith plate on a level
and can kind of control
the trajectory of the arc
of where the player is going to fly.
And this arc is not really
visible to the player,
but it's pretty apparent
based on the level design.
So you can see in this one, I'm going
to play the video as I'm talking
and then maybe play
it a couple of times.
So the tech that was developed
for these Aerial Faith Plates
is something that we
reuse for a fling helper.
So you can see here there's all these--
I'm going to turn on some debug draw.
And you can see right here.
So this green arc here is the
arc that's on the faith plates,
but you can see there's some stuff
coming out of the walls there as well.
So this is a part of the level where
the player is going to fling out of.
He's going to fling a box out of that
actually because he wanted this to work
for objects as well as the player.
So you can see as the
box goes through here
and then here, these
are those faith plates.
And then when the box
comes out of that, we
have the box follow the arc
that's kind of predetermined.
Because that's I think what the
player is expecting at that point.
They expected to have solved
the solution-- solve the puzzle.
But the funnel, the trigger here--
this kind of corrects the arc to
make sure that it's always going
to go in the place the player expects.
And we also have a case of the
same things working for the player.
So you can see here there's
two different arcs that
are coming out because we doubled
up the triggers over here.
The way these triggers
worked in the game
is they won't always enable
when the player touches them.
They require a minimum
velocity threshold.
So the player has to be
doing most of the work.
So the player has to have
figured out a way in the level
through the puzzle design
to get that velocity.
But we know that there's some
differences in physics and differences
in the exact mechanism you might use.
So we're just saying if you got the
minimum velocity that we acquire,
we're going to take
it all the way there.
So in this one, you can see
we have two different cases.
So if I just fall out of the portal,
it's not going to activate any of them.
If I somehow manage
to get some velocity,
is going to activate the fail
case one and take me there.
And the reason we have
the fail case one is
because we want to make sure
that if players somehow get
most of the velocity
but bonk on the wall,
they don't keep thinking that they
can-- that's the correct way to do it.
So we want to make it
obvious that you failed.
So again it's the same way.
We have to help-- you're helping the
players out but not by giving them
the solution.
Just by making it obvious that the
thing you did was correct or wrong.
And then if you do the correct
way in this level, which
is to get philosophy doing that,
and then you make a portal there,
you're going to do the correct
thing and swing out of it.
And again, the main idea here is to
get rid of those false negatives.
Especially here because there's
a few different spots on the wall
that you can put a portal.
And we don't really want
to restrict a lot of that
and just put the one square on the wall.
That is the solution square.
Because again, if you put the portal
down here or put the portal up here,
the arc is going to
be slightly different.
So this mechanism we had
just kind of corrects
those arcs and makes sure that it goes
in the one or two ways that we want.
Another thing we added in--
this we added in Portal 2--
was highlights for your
portals so you can see where
your portals are placed through walls.
And this is something that's
super useful in levels
where you have to keep track of
which portal you placed over there.
So you know which one
to place over here.
Because sometimes it's like, OK,
I just got out of the blue one
and the orange one's over there.
So if I place the blue one--
oh, I got to do the whole puzzle again
now because I placed the wrong one.
So this helps a lot in just making sure
that you know where your portals are
so you can be like I want
to come out of that one,
so I'm going to place the other one.
And this is something we added in
Portal 2 and it was pretty helpful.
And it's also helpful in the
co-op version of the game.
Because in the co-op
one, you want to see
where both the players'
portals are at all times
and this kind mechanic helps in that.
Another thing we added to kind
of help the player a little bit
is a thing we call the placement helper.
And this does not use a
whole lot in the game,
but there's a few
sections in the game where
we want to encourage
the players to come out
of a portal in a particular direction.
So we have these things that we place
in the level with a certain radius.
And if you place a portal
within that radius,
we just kind of snap
it to the direction--
to the center of it.
But they don't a timer.
So if you place one
portal and you're like,
oh, I actually want to place it over
here, you can always opt out of it.
And that's again what
I was talking earlier.
You want to add something-- excuse me.
You want to add these helpers in a
way that, for players, they're mostly
invisible to most of the players.
But the players that want to opt out of
them have a way of opting out of them.
[COUGHS]
Excuse me.
So you can see the first portal
that's placed does get snapped,
but the second one that's placed
is exactly where the player wanted.
And we use these in a
few spots in the game,
but they weren't used a whole
lot because for the most part
you want to have-- you want
to make sure the player feels
like they're in control.
And one of the other things
that was a lot of fun
while making Portal, and Dave
will talk a lot about this--
excuse me-- will talk a lot about
this later is the physics of portals,
or physics of objects
interacting with portals.
And for the most part we're trying
to be super accurate with it, right?
We're trying to make stuff work
the way players expect in real life
because that's kind of what
we're trying to simulate here.
But one of the things that we thought
that we added here-- that we thought
was more fun than accurate.
So you can see the--
[COUGHING]
Sorry, I'm a little bit sick.
You can see here that
when the box starts off,
it's just resting on the floor.
So it's got no initial
velocity whatsoever.
So when you place the blue
portal down, the expectation
is probably that it keeps
resting there or maybe it
goes in the center of the
portal and just stands there.
But that's not a super
fun game mechanic.
So here we just have it be so
that objects coming out of portals
have some minimum velocity.
So they always have
some minimum velocity.
And this works in lots of other
parts of the game like the paint.
And you can see here
that there is some air
resistance that takes place and
the paint does slowly come down.
But once it comes down to this
minimum velocity, it just stays there.
And this is-- it's like
completely fabricated fiction.
I guess there's no
real physics for this.
It's just kind of like this is more fun
than trying to simulate real physics.
So you can see here air
resistance is making
it go down, like they're slowing down.
But once they get to the minimum
velocity, they just stay there.
This is about it.
So once it gets here, it's
just going to stay here.
It's not going to go below that.
And speaking of gels, the
gels actually came up--
were an idea that we
had for our student game
that we made while we were in DigiPen.
It was called "Tag--
The Power of Paint."
And in Tag, you had a paint gun that
you used to shoot the different colors.
And the Portal 2 mechanic was adapted
from this and it's pretty similar.
But one of the things we
did get rid of for Portal 2
was the idea of having the paint gun.
Because one of the core ideas
we had while working on Portal 2
was that any mechanics we add to the
game should really work with portals
and should really interact
at a core level with portals.
So we thought instead of using
a gun to move the paint around,
it will made much more sense to use
the portals to move the paint around.
And that was kind of core not just with
the gels, but with any new mechanic
we added to the game.
Was that portals is the
core idea of the games.
Everything we do should kind of
center around how portals work.
I'm just showing you the
different colors we had in Tag.
One of the colors that we added
in Portal that wasn't there in Tag
was the portal gel.
And this was again going
with the idea of how
do we make the gels and the
portals interact better.
So this one just lets you
spread around white paint
so you can put portals
anywhere that the paint can go.
And this is a pretty
cool mechanic in that
it allows for a lot more open-ended
level design and a lot more player
freedom.
Because you can play portals
essentially anywhere now.
Because for a lot of the
game we're restricting
where the players can put portals on
the black surface or the white surface.
And this just allows--
you can just put white anywhere
and put portals anywhere.
We didn't use this a whole lot
because it is pretty open-ended
and it does break a
lot of puzzle designs.
But there are a few cases where we
use it in a pretty open-ended way
and have the player
just kind of have fun.
Spend some time painting the whole
level and then figuring out what to do.
And these kind of levels usually
have a couple of different solutions
because we don't know where
the players are going to paint.
So we just put a bunch of different
ways to get to the exit and players.
Some players figure out all the knobs.
Some players find the first
one and just go there.
And it helps to break up the pacing a
little bit from the conventional puzzle
design with the specific spots where
here are some white spots, here
are some black spots.
So it helps break that up a little bit.
One of the things that didn't make
it through from our student game
was the sticky gel that you
saw in the student version.
So this is going to
look a little bit broken
because this is from a really
old version of Portal 2
because the sticky gel
got cut pretty early on.
And you're going to see some
stuff here that doesn't really
make sense, but just go with it.
So you can see we used
purple instead of blue here.
So you can jump on-- you can walk on
walls and stuff, which is pretty cool.
So here you can see there's
blue paint coming out of there
but you can't see the actual
paint blobs because there
are invisible for some reason.
I couldn't figure it out.
But you can see the actual paint
on the walls, on the floor.
So this is just an idea
of the kind of puzzles
we were trying to come up
with using sticky paint.
There's an extra portal
there for some reason.
Ignore it.
This is a really old
version of the game.
So this is the kind of puzzles
we are trying to come up with.
Of combining the different paint
colors and portals together.
But we did end up cutting
this feature though.
There were a few different reasons.
One of them was obviously
it is quite disorienting.
You can see going up a wall
and trying to figure out where
the ceiling is, where the floor is.
Especially in a lot
of these levels where
they're mostly just black and white.
It gets pretty disorienting
and we had more than a few play
testers complain about that.
But the other big reason that we
cut it is because it didn't really
interact well with portals.
You don't really want
to walk into a level
and have the pots
already placed for you.
And there's no real good way
to make pots on the entire wall
without having to place
the portal like 50 times.
And also it didn't really interact
well with the portal player
physics and portal physics, and Dave
will talk some more about the player
physics through portals.
And this is one of the
things that you can see.
We had a paint gun for a little
bit, but we ended up cutting it.
So you can see I'm
painting the wall over here
and I'm going to walk on the wall.
But as I enter the blue
portal, you can see oh, it's
not going to let me go through.
But if I go through this way, it works.
And that's just one of the things that's
like, well, we've got to solve this.
We've got to ship like this.
We've got to solve the problems.
And we spent some time trying
to work on these issues.
But at some point, you
realize that you're not
guaranteed to solve these problems
no matter how long you spend on them.
So at some point you've
got to just be like, OK,
I don't want to spend
an extra month or two
trying to fix these problems
not knowing if you'll get there.
And plus there's other reasons why
the mechanic isn't working out.
So let's just stop working on this
and work on other stuff instead.
Another thing we ended up cutting--
this is from Portal 1 that was present
in Narbacular Drop was the ability
to place portals through portals.
And it's a pretty
confusing thing and that
was the main reason we cut
it because most players just
thought it was way too confusing.
Because you're placing the blue
portal by looking through the orange
portal here.
So the blue portal is--
he's pointing through the orange portal
here and facing the blue portal over
here because the other
blue portal is behind them.
It's just like-- it's too confusing.
And also it doesn't--
there's not a lot of puzzle design that
you lose by disabling this feature.
The thing you do gain is players
aren't getting super confused
and also you're not necessarily
cutting a bunch of puzzles
that you can't make now.
So this feature got cut as well.
And this is something
that we didn't really cut,
but we stopped using in Portal 2 that
was used a little bit in Portal 1
was the idea of a double fling.
And I'm going to show it here.
So double fling is
basically placing a portal
while you're falling out of a portal.
And it's one of those things
that it works pretty well.
It's a pretty cool mechanic.
And it was used in a
few spots in Portal 1.
A couple of puzzles required it,
like this puzzle here required you
to do this double fling.
But one of the things we
noticed was a lot of players
have difficulty in executing a
lot of these super hyper-sized,
high-precision movements
even though they know
what the solution of the puzzle is.
So players will walk in this room and
figure out, OK, I've got to do this,
I've got to do that, and
this is going to work.
But then a lot of players have
trouble walking out of a portal,
making a portal as quickly,
and it adds a lot of stress.
And we wanted to move away from a lot
of the twitch movement based stuff
and towards more of a
kind of, aha, I got it.
That kind of stuff.
And once you get it, we don't
want you to spend a bunch of time
in making sure you get the
precise movements right.
So this feature we didn't really cut it.
It's still a mechanic
that works in Portal 2,
but none of the puzzles in
Portal 2 required it anymore.
And once we added the level
editor, a lot of the puzzles people
are making do require it and
a lot of players like it.
But it's not something that we thought
we wanted to make everyone have to do.
Another thing that we changed
from Portal 1 to Portal 2
was these energy balls.
These energy balls at the time--
part of the reason we
used them in Portal 1
was because they were
there in Half-Life and it
was an already created mechanic that we
had that we could just keep from them.
But the basic mechanic
is these things fire--
these things fire this
ball that bounces around
and it needs to go in this receptacle
here under my gun right now.
And it should go in this receptacle
here and once it goes there,
it finishes the puzzle.
There are a few issues
with this mechanic, though,
in that there's a bunch of
timing element involved here.
Because the ball takes time to travel.
And also if you get hit by it, you die.
Which, I mean, it's fine.
It's a game mechanic
But for Portal 2, we just thought,
how can we improve on this idea?
And the thing we came up with was using
lasers instead of the energy balls.
Lower the volume a little bit.
So here you can see it it's
the same level from Portal 1
and you can even see the energy ball
dispenser going away and being replaced
by a laser because we want
to make sure the player is
like, GLaDOS is improving
these mechanics now
and got better versions of it.
So the laser effectively is
very similar to the energy ball.
It goes in one and you want it--
it goes in over here and you want it
to go to the receptacle over there.
The big advantage here is
that the reaction is instant.
So if the player got the solution
or not, it's instantaneous.
You don't have to have situations
where you place the exit portal
and now you have to wait for the ball
to go all the way across the level
and see if it lines up or not.
This way it just instantly does it.
Plus it also opens up a bunch of
different game play opportunities
because now you can use multiple
relays in the same level.
You can have the cube
that redirects the laser.
So overall it felt like an
improvement over the energy ball.
And talking about
lasers, so far we've been
talking about a bunch of
these smaller decisions we've
made to solve these smaller problems
as they kept coming up, like entering
exiting portals, making sure
things are lined up or not,
improving on the
specific game mechanics.
But one of the things
that you need to do
when you're trying to
make a whole game is
to see how these mechanics come together
and how you can combine them together
to make a whole game.
To make a few puzzles that increase
into difficulty, complexity,
and go towards some crescendo.
And one of the ways we did that is
by kind of using this kind of process
that I'm going to go through.
And we used it a couple of times
both in Portal 1 and in Portal 2.
And there's a few different mechanics
that we used the cycle over and over
for.
And that's kind of how the
entire game track is designed.
So it starts off with an
introduction, and the introduction
is the puzzle we just showed you.
That's the intro puzzle for lasers
and it's really straightforward.
It just shows you the mechanic.
You go through one portal, come out
the other, goes into the receptacle.
It's really straightforward.
Introduces the mechanic.
Most people would get
tripped up on this.
From there, we then try to saturate
the player with that same mechanic.
We introduce different
twists on that same--
without introducing
a whole new mechanic,
we just introduce different versions,
different tweaks on that same idea.
So this room still only has lasers.
But now we've introduced
relays and cubes.
And you can experiment, figure out how
to connect the three lasers together.
Figure out how to move
the cube, figure out
how to move the laser
through the portals.
But still it's only lasers.
Nothing super complex yet.
Then we give you more of that.
We give you more of
just the same mechanic.
Here there's two things firing lasers
and two things you've got to connect.
And so it's the same idea.
It's like just using lasers,
but not super complex.
Just building on the
complexity little by little.
Followed by a puzzle
that's like, OK, this
is a puzzle that's going to
teach you all about lasers.
By now you've seen lasers
in a few different ways.
This one, once you get this,
you understand how lasers work.
You know everything there is
to know about how lasers work.
So this puzzle here--
excuse me-- that's two cubes
and three things firing lasers,
and on the other side
of the puzzle there's
three things-- you've
got to connect them.
And this puzzle is very
difficult, but by this point,
you've been slowly
introduced to different ideas
of how lasers work and this one
is taking them all together.
And then once we've done that,
then we start combining them.
Then we start taking, OK,
now you've got a laser
and a different cube and a bridge.
And by this point you've
seen a whole separate--
we've done the whole introduction,
saturation, graduation track
with bridges as well.
So by this point, you
go in there and, OK, I
know how bridges, I
know how lasers work.
How do they work together?
How do I combine them together?
And then we start escalating from there.
And then you go into this puzzle
that has a bridge, has a laser,
has a turret, has some cubes
coming out, has a catapult,
has a bunch of this stuff.
But by the time the
player gets here, they're
not really overwhelmed
by it because they
have been introduced to all these
mechanics separately and also
smaller combinations of them.
So that when they get
to this point where
there's a bunch of
different mechanics, they
know how they all work individually.
And that's kind of the process
that we use of slowly ramping up
the difficulty, first with a single
mechanic, then combining them.
And then that's kind of how we take
the individual smaller design elements
and combine them together and
turn them into the whole game.
And now I think Dave is going to come
back and talk some more about physics.
DAVE KIRCHER: And after I cover
these last four bits of physics,
we're going to open up for questions.
I know we have a whole miscellaneous
section that we've outlined here,
but that's more just buffer material.
So I'm hoping you're going to put
your spatial thinking caps back on.
So how we handle portal transitions
is there's two distinct methods.
One is that we've got volumes here,
which we call touch volumes or trigger
volumes.
And those are centered
around the portal.
So I've got my blue portal here
and that was green volumes here.
And you'll notice it's entirely
in front of the portal--
that's important.
And then we've got this
yellow volume here.
So the yellow volume is--
it's whole job is to tell us
which objects in the world
are just kind of close to a
portal, and I'll come back
to why that's important to the minute.
But it separates us from
having to think about objects
that are way out in the world all
over in the white space around here.
We don't have to think about them.
And we also know they're not
objects behind the portal
because we're only interested in stuff
that happens in front of the portal.
And this green volume here is
where most of the magic happens.
This volume says the objects
in it are so close to a portal
we need to think very hard about what
they can do and what they can't do.
We're going to let those objects
start passing through the portal.
And so we keep these objects
in two separate lists.
Objects that are in this green volume
no longer intersect with any objects
out in the white space out here.
They don't have to think about them.
They're kept in a
completely separate list
and they don't collide with them at all.
They also don't collide
with world geometry.
I'll get to that in a bit.
And then objects in
this yellow volume are
the only ones that the objects in
the green volume have to worry about.
So these are objects that are
just kind of close to a portal.
And so another important interaction
with portals is ray casting.
So we're only interested in rays
that pass through the portal quad.
So if a ray happens to
just pass the portal plane,
but not intersect the quad,
we don't do anything with it.
It's not special.
We just treat it like any
other ray in the world
and let it do its merry thing.
But we got this magenta guy.
It intersects with the portal.
So now we have to recast a new ray
out the other orange portal which
essentially gives us two ray segments.
And if you think about that, if you
were to write any piece of code that
just did the ray casting and
hand back two ray segments
when somebody was expecting one, you're
probably going to get weird results.
So this means, the fact
that this is happening,
means that we have to go through every
single system in the game that possibly
casts a ray through a portal and
fix every single one to understand.
But if we give you back multiple
segments, different things happen.
Instead of assuming that this
starting point goes directly
to this end point, which
doesn't even go in the direction
it wanted to in the first place.
And so at its core,
remember how I told you
every object had an
origin, a single point that
defines where it is in space.
We use the ray casting to
determine if an object that's
in this green volume and
just kind of moving around.
We use a recast from
one point where it was
one frame to one point
where it was another frame
to see if it either passed through
a portal or outside the portal
because if it went over this
way, we do nothing at all.
If we went this way,
we need to teleport it.
So that's the basics of our handling.
So how do we let objects
pass through walls?
This is one of the things
I spent a whole lot of time
on because we wanted our portal
transitions to be very seamless.
Remember in one of my
first slides I showed you.
It should be like a door.
People expect to walk halfway through
the door and just stand there.
And how we do this is--
I'm going to talk about it a bit first.
Whenever you place a portal, we take
a snapshot of all the world geometry
around you and create a very
small representation of that
and carve a hole in it.
And we don't do this for the entire
world because that takes way too long.
And by way too long, I
mean a quarter of a second.
And in game terms,
that's just way too long.
I don't know if it was
a quarter of a second.
I remember originally that
we had a problem where
I think carving the mini-version
took a quarter of a second,
so it probably took several seconds.
So I'm going to show you a scenario
here where I've got a portal
and it's going into--
it's going along this corridor
gateway, gangplank thing.
And it's going to go into
this little classroom area.
And as I go back around
the wall, I'm going
to show you a debug mesh of
our collision representation.
So in this debug representation,
we've got these green lines.
These green lines and then
also these cyan lines--
or I'm probably mispronouncing that.
I call them bluish, but my colleague
has told me I need to call him cyan.
[CHUCKLING]
So I'm going to call them bluish now.
So these green lines and the
blue lines are in local space.
So they're with the blue
portal that we placed locally.
And I know it's super
hard to see, but there
are a bunch of red lines over
here and some magenta ones.
Those are from the other portal
that's in the classroom that
are flipped and glued to the
back of our local portal.
So it's all in this local space
and around this blue portal.
We put some new stuff behind it
and some new stuff in front of it.
And so you may be asking yourself
what the colors actually mean?
Green here is representing a brush
geometry, which most level editors, you
can create walls and various shapes
directly in the level editor.
And at least in our terminology,
we refer to these as brushes.
So they're usually very simple convex
shapes and super easy to deal with.
And this bluish geometry
is from what's known
as a static prop, which is a model that
somebody modeled in a model editor.
So it's going to be
arbitrarily complex, but it
has to be made up of convex shapes.
But we take a small snapshot
of that and then carve it up.
Sorry, I forgot to mention.
So we call it a static prop because
we are guaranteed it does not move.
And that's very important because it's
really easy to simulate things that
don't move.
They don't move.
And the same is true of
the red and magenta here.
The red is the brush geometry
on the paired portal side
and the magenta is static props on the
other side, which is mainly the desks.
And as I'm looking through here.
You can see just a small
snapshot, and then you
can see this magenta outline here
of the desk mesh on the other side.
It's important to know that
that's not me looking at the mesh
through the portal.
That's the local space
version and it just
happens to line up the desk because we
have to make sure everything lines up.
Otherwise your physical
interactions will seem weird
if something is halfway
in a portal and it's
kind of not colliding with something
or it's colliding with it wrong.
As I walk through, you'll
notice all the colors
change because we switched spaces
when I walk through in a second.
So now all the colors are
local space for this side.
So, yeah, that is how we carve a hole.
It's a very, very small area of
the level that we carve a hole in.
And so we're getting back to the
volumes I showed you two slides ago.
If we carve a small
representation of the world,
we have to know when
the player is colliding
with that versus the regular world.
Because if they're colliding
with the regular world,
they're going to collide with
the wall that's behind the portal
and they're not going to go through it.
So we have to use exclusively
that carved version
when they're close to a portal.
And we do that-- we're using the same
volumes I was talking about earlier.
This is a 3D representation of them.
And you'll notice that they have space--
a large amount of space
above and below the portal.
That's important because it's a
3D space instead of a 2D space.
So as I enter the yellow space,
I still collide with the world.
I still collide with all
the desks and things.
Because I'm still-- while I'm
exclusively in the yellow volume,
I'm still colliding with the world.
I'm going to show you.
It's a bad example, but
it's the video I've got.
I'm going to hit this
chair behind this desk
because it's still in the real world.
And then as I transition
into the green volume,
I am exclusively colliding
with our carved version of it.
Which-- that was a bad frame to cut.
If I happen to look back in the portal--
which side is scrubbing?
OK.
Sorry.
So if you happen to look inside the
portal, you might be able to see it.
There is-- I know it's super
hard to see, I'm sorry.
But we did carve a hole.
There's no there's no geometry
right here to stop us going in.
And since we're exclusively
using this new mesh,
we're allowed to just
go through that space.
OK, so more importantly
than static geometry, which
doesn't move and is super
easy to physically simulate,
we have dynamic props
and things that move.
Specifically in this case, boxes.
So the way we model this is very
similar to how we did with geometry.
We're going to be duplicating
everything and I'm
going to show you by
walking in a portal.
So this blue box that just
appeared is my player.
My player of physics object that's
replicated from this orange portal
to the backside of the blue portal.
And this is using a system
known as a physics shadow.
At least that's what our system is.
I'm not really a physicist.
That's just what we call
our representation of it.
So I mean, I haven't dealt with many
physics systems when I talk about that.
So what a physics shadow
does that's different
than our rendering geometry is we're
not allowed to actually teleport it
from one frame to the next
because if you teleport a physics
object, then all sorts of
interactions that intersect,
they have no previous basis to go from.
Of like how to solve that.
They can't rewind time because
they've suddenly teleported
into an interpenetrating space.
So all of our physics objects--
we give them a target of
where they need to go.
Sorry not all of our
physics options are shadows.
So just like the player volume and just
the examples I'm about to give you.
We told them where we want them
to go and they try their best
to apply forces and rotations to
go there, but if it doesn't work,
we're kind of SOL and
they do their best.
So I'm replicating that
for the player over there.
And we're also going to replicate
it for the cubes in a second
once I get around to placing them.
And so it's important to
note that we're not really
solving the discontinuity
in space because that
would be way too hard, at least
for a person of my skill level.
What we're doing is we're
saying each side has--
this cube over here is the master of
it's physics and this cube over here
is the master of its own physics.
And this cube over here is
just trying to replicate
whatever this guy is doing.
So they don't quite line up,
but they work well enough.
And in game development, good
enough usually goes a long way.
So as I'm using it, you might notice
they don't quite work super well,
but you can see that I've got
this representation over here.
I'm pushing it in my virtual version
and it's all lining up kind of.
And, yeah, that's how
we do it in Portal.
So I'm going to go ahead and tell
you that I'm really glad that we
didn't have levels with more than two
cubes because if you try to do this
with a train of cubes-- three or four--
it breaks down horribly.
And this last little bit
is me just showing you
that we're not intersecting
with anything in the back of it
because we're not inside the
green volume or the yellow volume
because we're behind the portal.
It's really important to manage your
lists of what can interact with what
when we're faking holes in
space and overlapping space.
I spent a whole lot of time on this.
And I think that is the end
of our physics material.
So we had some more
miscellaneous filler material,
but it looks like we've ran over
a little bit of our initial time.
So we're going to open up to Q&A now.
We might get to our
miscellaneous material later.
But, yeah, if anybody has got
questions, now would be a good time.
AUDIENCE: Could you talk a little bit
about how lights interact with portals,
or just lighting on objects and, like,
will you get shadows from the portal?
DAVE KIRCHER: So originally,
I had a slide on that.
TEJEEV KOHLI: The
question was about lights.
DAVE KIRCHER: Oh, sorry.
Yes, sorry.
The question was how lights interact
with portals and shadows and things.
So I'm going to preface with saying that
most of this stuff I did a decade ago.
So if I say something that's
not true, I'm not trying to lie.
I just don't remember it.
So basically there was
a time during Portal 1
where we tried very hard to
make light work through portals
and we kind of settled
on a cheap solution.
Where we would define a point
barely in front of one portal,
see what lights were projecting
what amount of color on that,
and just kind of make it a massive
sphere on the other side that
would kind of do that.
So the downside was is
that you only noticed it
in cases that were very high contrast,
which is also the case in where
it was the most broken.
So we just don't do it.
TEJEEV KOHLI: On Portal
2, we tried for a while
to have the portals themselves
project light on things
and that was also kind
of broken for a while.
And then we just took it out.
DAVE KIRCHER: Yes, so we
just punted on that one.
Too hard.
TEJEEV KOHLI: Any other questions?
Yeah, sure.
AUDIENCE: What were the
performance implications
of having to draw on that
stencil buffer multiple times?
DAVE KIRCHER: So the question
was what were the performance
implications of having to draw multiple
scenes with the stencil buffer.
So it's very analogous having to
just draw a more complex scene.
You're just drawing
more quads and things.
On one of the slides in
our miscellaneous section--
you know what?
Why don't I just go
ahead and jump to it?
So it's very important.
So when we're rendering
things in a 3D space,
we have what's known as a frustum.
It's kind of a pyramid, which
comes out from your camera.
And you can use it as a very quick
test to see if you should even
bother rendering something at all.
So I've got--
I'm going to use my side--
my sides.
The sides are defined
by the screen itself.
So the screen that you're
drawing has a top, has a bottom,
so those project into space.
So we take our one side we can
say, OK, if an object is completely
on the other side of
this plane, we don't even
need to bother trying to draw it.
We can just skip it.
And so one of the
optimizations we have in Portal
is that every time you
look through a portal,
we can find the frustum
to a smaller space.
I took the easy route in that
I kept it as an object that
still had four distinct sides.
So sometimes it's a little bit broken.
But in this case, you can see--
in this case, you can see I'm
looking through a blue portal
at this little button here.
And I've got this-- it's
probably impossible to see,
but I've got this mesh coming out.
This is the updated frustum
of everything we try to draw.
So you can see it mostly just
encapsulates a little bit of level
and the button itself, and that
helps us not even attempt to draw
the complete scene over and over again.
But I don't think I ever
did a performance analysis,
so I can't give you concrete numbers.
But it was better than trying to draw
the entire scene over and over again.
Because since we still had
the depth buffer on our side,
we had already drawn most of the screen.
And then we also had the
stencil buffer telling us
not to even attempt to
draw most of the pixels.
It was not nearly as bad as
trying to render the entire scene.
But we did find that for the graphics
cards of the day, which not even
all of them supported stencil buffers.
Some people that played
Portal 1, they got textures.
We found it was best to
just limit to two recursions
because we could do our depth,
or we could do our recursion fake
and it worked pretty well.
And I don't think it
was terribly expensive
even for the cards of the day.
TEJEEV KOHLI: I know there
were cases during Portal 2
when we were trying to
make it work on consoles,
there was a lot of proof tests.
There were four cases,
especially in co-op,
when you're playing in split-screen with
four portals on screen at the same time
all looking at each other.
It's like 16 views being rendered of
the entire world at the same time.
And there were these like
weird edge cases where like,
if you do that, you get
two frames per second.
Just don't do that.
[LAUGHING]
There was a few things in
levels that had changed where--
like the corner case was the worst.
Where if you have a
wall like that and you
can put a portal right next to each
other on both sides of the corner.
So we had a couple of cases where
we had to actually change the levels
to not have those cases.
So you can't play--
so we just moved the corners
apart like 16 units or whatever.
So you can't always see both
portals through both the views.
So there was stuff like that we
had to work through especially
for consoles back in the day.
Like we were working on PS3 360s.
I'm sure now it's better, but it's
been a long time since we've done that.
DAVE KIRCHER: If I remember
correctly, using stenciling
was strictly less expensive
than using textures,
because you're still going to
draw the same amount of geometry,
but you have no texture cost whatsoever.
Hopefully that answers most of that.
AUDIENCE: How did you cover all
of your bases for each level,
so that a player could never get stuck?
In the sense that if
you fell off a cliff
or maybe accidentally erased a portal,
you could always find a way to go back
or to keep progressing forward?
TEJEEV KOHLI: The
question was about how we
covered our bases to make sure the
players can't get stuck in levels
if they do something bad.
Mostly through play testing and
then later on through bug testing.
It's a lot of just trying to make sure
that you can see parts of the level
from different parts.
Towards the later process of when
we're getting closer to shipping,
we do something called the
greasy pig pass for the levels.
Where we make sure the players can't
literally get stuck on walls and stuff
as they're walking through them.
So we have a bunch of
invisible geometry there
that'll make smooth the collisions
along stairs and along--
because especially in Portal 2,
there's a bunch of these broken pieces
and a bunch of foliage and
broken parts of the levels
that are tilted at
weird angles and stuff.
And it's like for the most
part, we left them as is.
But a lot of cases we had to
go in and put invisible stuff
everywhere to make sure
that the wall might
look like it's broken up into
like 15 different pieces,
but the player's just
colliding with a flat plane.
It's to make sure that those
things don't happen where
the players don't get stuck in spots.
And there's also a bunch of level design
work that goes around and making sure--
because we have to take care
of the opposite as well, right?
We have to take care of,
well, we've got to make
sure the player can see the exit
portal from the start of the level
so they can't just portal and
portal and get to the end.
And so doing that process helps
with what you are asking as well.
Because if you can make sure
that the exploits aren't there,
you're also getting rid of cases
where the player can get themselves
in a bad spot.
And so it kind of works itself out
through the course of development.
You don't go in starting
to make a puzzle
or making a level with
that in mind a whole lot.
But as you start refining it, things
get tweaked and things get tuned.
Some things you might be have
to tweak for like port reasons.
Like this doesn't work on PS3.
So you got to go, OK, I got to fix
this and tweak the puzzle a little bit.
But then once you tweak
the puzzle, now you've
got to do the whole
testing all over again.
Because all right, I can't just
put a portal place on there
because now you can solve the
puzzle without doing any of it.
So there's a bunch of work that
has to go on from that sense.
DAVE KIRCHER: And it's
important to note that as we
get closer to shipping a product,
more and more of our dev team
switches to play testing.
And we have some very smart
and mischievous people
that that specific question of how
do you make sure you don't get stuck
is on the checklist.
It was on my checklist
at least of, like, I am
going to make sure I can't get stuck.
I'm going to sit in this
level for about half an hour
and think long and hard about
how to get myself stuck.
And if I can't do it, then pass.
[CHUCKLES]
AUDIENCE: Was there anything that
you would have liked to have pursued,
but didn't, due to either
time constraints on shipping
or the limitations of graphics cards
of the day that you thought about,
but for whatever reason, couldn't do?
DAVE KIRCHER: The question
was was there anything
that we didn't pursue for
various reasons before shipping?
And I can't think of anything.
I think I was pretty happy
with what we produced.
Most of the things I
focused on were bugs
that we shipped because once again,
getting back into shipping mode,
as you get closer to
shipping something, you
want to touch the code
less and less and less.
Even if you know that the fix is going
to work 100%, it will definitely work,
it might break something new.
So I certainly have a small list of
things that I wished I had fixed,
but nothing that I wish I--
AUDIENCE: Basically, like, features
like the sticky paint, for example.
DAVE KIRCHER: Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I can't think
of any features that--
TEJEEV KOHLI: There's stuff
that we worked on that
obviously didn't ed up shipping.
Some of them we touched on over here.
I don't know if sticky
paint was something
that we should have
worked more on, though,
because I feel like we spent a lot
of time trying to get it to work.
And the reasons for cutting
it then are still valid now.
So I'm saying if we were
to go back, I don't think
we would try to solve that problem.
We'd probably come up with
new problems to try to solve.
We did have-- like
another thing we tried
was I think we tried it after the game
shipped for like a DLC expansion was
reflection paint.
So it was paint that would reflect
the different elements of the games
like reflect lasers or
reflect light bridges.
And we didn't get too far with it.
Again, it leads to a
bunch of weird levels
because you have to have
all levels have angles.
Because if you think about
Portal, most of the levels
are like 90 degree walls and stuff.
And 90 degree reflections
don't go anywhere.
So we had to have--
make this super contrived looking
levels with these weird 45 degree angles
everywhere and they can reflect things.
And then all the problems
like, well, how often--
how many bounces do we allow and things.
And also stuff just looked weird,
like tractor beams reflecting off
of walls just looked weird.
There's probably other ideas
that I can't remember right now,
but there are--
a lot of them get cut short pretty quick
because the flaws are really apparent
pretty quickly.
You might sit down and think,
oh, this is a great idea.
I'm going to go out and work on it.
And then as you start working through
it and testing it out with others,
you start seeing all the problems.
And those problems get
apparent pretty quickly.
And at that point, you make the call.
Just be like, this is not
worth pursuing anymore.
We had some more game modes
we were trying to work on.
I think we had a competitive mode
for a little bit we worked on.
DAVE KIRCHER: We actually have a
slide about that for a little bit.
It didn't get fleshed out.
But after Portal shipped,
we immediately said
to ourself what does
multiplayer look like?
And so the first thing
we tried was deathmatch.
Turns out that's a horrible idea.
Everybody wants to just put
portals under other people's feet.
So you spend most of your time just
completely disoriented or confused.
And then I think we made a
collect the coins kind of like,
oh, do flings and things.
But once again, everybody
wanted to put their portals
under other people's feet.
So now we have co-op.
TEJEEV KOHLI: The co-op was
very successful, I think.
And there's a bunch of
other challenges that come
with co-op that we had to work through.
I think, yeah, we tried some
more different competitive modes.
We tried a time trial kind of mode,
but they're doing it together.
But that's effectively just playing two
single player games at the same time.
So there's not much interaction.
Any time you let players interact
in a competitive way in Portal,
they just want to put
portals on their feet.
That's really all they want to do.
It's fun for a bit, but not
as the receiving end, right?
It's not fun-- or they just want to
keep bumping each other's portals.
Like when they want to put their
portal at exactly where the other guy's
portal is.
Like they walk in and
they go in there instead
of where they were supposed to go.
It's fun for a bit.
I'm not saying there's no merit there.
DAVE KIRCHER: By "a bit," I think
he means about five minutes.
TEJEEV KOHLI: Yeah, by "a bit," that's
the thing you look at, you're like, ah,
that's funny.
But then you realize there's no real--
at least in the mechanics we tried,
there wasn't much depth to it.
It's not something you could
flesh out for a game mode.
It's more of something
you could do as a level--
as a gimmick once.
But then there's not
much reason to do that.
The cost of doing that is really
high, so you have to figure out
do you want to spend
a bunch of dev effort
in making this gimmick that's going
to get really old and lots of people
are going to get annoyed or frustrated?
So you just don't do that.
In the back there.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned that
you could cache some stuff--
things in the pipeline for
some of the lighting plots--
earlier.
I'm wondering if there were any
other kind of hardware hacks
that you do in order to keep the targets
that you want for the portal behavior?
DAVE KIRCHER: So the question
references how there were some pipeline
restraints on the pixel queries.
And if there were any hacks that
we had to do to meet performance,
I believe yes.
TEJEEV KOHLI: And any
other stuff we did.
DAVE KIRCHER: Once
again, I'm going to have
to say that I did most of
this stuff 10 years ago.
I can't think of anything
off the top of my head.
There wasn't a whole lot.
TEJEEV KOHLI: We did
stuff with the paint.
I don't know if we did a
bunch of hacks, but one
of the big hacks on the paint that we
did was the paint that you're seeing
is not the paint that's
doing the painting.
So I mean that's, like, nobody can tell.
That's pretty good.
But especially on multiplayer, the
paint that the client is seeing
is not the paint that
the server is seeing.
Because we couldn't
transmit all that data,
so they're both
generating their own data.
But then the server is the only
one doing the actual painting,
so all the blobs that the client
is hitting in the world do nothing
and the server blobs do the painting and
then tell the client paint over there,
paint over there.
So that's the kind of thing-- because
the network bandwidth is pretty limited
and there's a lot of paint
flying through the world.
So we couldn't just transmit
all the paint all the time,
so they all generate their own paint.
Blobs that are through the
world, and then the painting
itself happened on the server
and then that gets transmitted.
But the paint flying through the
air is different on everyone,
but it's random enough
that you can't really tell.
AUDIENCE: Is Half-Life
3 going to have portals?
TEJEEV KOHLI: I don't know.
DAVE KIRCHER: No comment.
[LAUGHTER]
Probably not.
In all seriousness, after
the initial Portal came out,
one of the other experiments was not
only what does multiplayer look like,
but how fun is this in
a Half-Life environment?
And it turns out that the
way that Half-Life is made,
there are a whole lot of slightly
scripted sequences to make things work.
And so the way those
levels are designed are
fundamentally different
than Portal levels
and they basically just break down.
So if there were portals in
Half-Life, then Half-Life
would seem a lot more like Portal.
TEJEEV KOHLI: If you think about a
Portal level, it's pretty constrained.
The sight lines are pretty constrained.
The level takes place in a box.
You can't see really far.
There's a lot of kinks in the walls so
you can't see all the way to the end.
Half-Life levels aren't
designed like that at all.
So you would just go in a level and
make portals all the way to the exit
and then skip all the game play.
I mean there are probably mods
that allow you to do that,
but I think the games themselves
and the mechanics are fundamentally
different enough that I don't
think they interact really well.
Unless both of them
change or one of them
changes a lot so it's no
longer the game you wanted.
I think you were up first.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned that you had
done, like, a student game project
before you got hired by Valve?
What was the story there?
TEJEEV KOHLI: So the question was
asking about our student game projects.
So Dave worked-- we both went to a
school in Redmond called DigiPen.
Dave went there before I did.
DAVE KIRCHER: I graduated in 2005.
I worked on a game
called Narbacular Drop.
Which if you Google for it,
it will be the only result
because the name was chosen so that
would be the only result on Google.
If you could spell it, good luck.
And so that was our senior
project at DigiPen--
my team at the time.
And so we ended up through a very
convoluted long story showing
that at Valve, and they
hired us on the spot
to basically recreate
those mechanics for them.
And that was actually--
there wasn't a whole lot
of confidence at the time that would
actually ship, but it became Portal.
So it seemed like a good thing.
TEJEEV KOHLI: Yeah, and I was
part of a team that made "Tag--
The Power of Paint," the video I
showed with a paint gun, and that
was our team's junior
project at DigiPen.
And same thing, Valve
saw it a couple of times
and hired the entire team to come
work on that mechanic at Valve.
And then once we got there, it
became obvious to try to integrate it
into Portal 2 and that's how
we start working on Portal 2
and that's how the
Portal 2 gels came about.
AUDIENCE: The paints and gels which were
introduced as a mechanic in Portal 2
ended up being part
of the story as well.
Can you talk about how some
mechanics end up affecting the story
and how story elements end
up affecting the mechanics?
TEJEEV KOHLI: The question was about
how the story and the game mechanics
interact and how one affects the other.
So the way at least in Portal 2, and
I think Portal 1 was very similar.
The way it kind of works
with Valve is we don't really
have an overarching design for a design
doc for the game before we start.
It's a lot of smaller things that we
try to combine using similar techniques
like what we discussed today.
And the story kind of builds us
out of using the same techniques.
Because the way we kind of vet
out most of our design decisions
is by play testing.
And the story follows a very similar
plot but you don't really want one--
either one to override the other.
Because if you see the game,
like if I make a bunch--
if we have a team that
made a bunch of puzzles
for the game that haven't
been very play tested.
And then the writer comes in and
does a bunch of writing for it
and then you realize three weeks later
that half these levels aren't shipping
anymore because they
didn't test well, then
you made a bunch of dependencies
that didn't really work.
Portal was lucky in that the puzzles
themselves are compartmentalized
as you enter the elevator.
Or you exit the elevator, you do
a puzzle, and enter the elevators.
So they're all pretty compartmentalized.
And a lot of the writing that was done
for it was essentially just jokes.
So a lot of those jokes do
fit in to most of the puzzles.
So the puzzle can change and the
joke can just be inserted into it.
But for the overarching
story of the game,
I think that required a
lot more collaboration.
So the writers were on-site.
They were Valve employees and
they were sitting in the same room
as us watching us play test,
bouncing back and forth ideas.
And we used-- we had GLaDOS
for most of the game.
And the voice artist was local,
so we had her come in many times
and record a bunch of lines.
We also used some like fake
online robot voice for a while,
but those are hard to judge
because the play testers almost
never laugh at those jokes.
Because the robot always doesn't
really know how to speak them.
But it sounds like a robot so
it's not it's better than nothing.
It's better than just putting
text on the screen, which we also
did for a while.
So with the writing, there's two things
that you're trying to test, right?
You're trying to test out the
individual's jokes, and a lot of them
can be transported to any level.
So they're not super
dependent on the levels.
But then once the story
starts coming together
and starts taking shape, at that point
you're making changes to the levels
to accommodate the story.
And from that point on, you have to
have a pretty good amount of confidence
that these particular levels
are going to ship in the game.
And so that that starts
happening I think fairly late
into our dev cycle at least.
There's always an overarching goal.
There's always a goal of you're
trying to capture Wheatley
or you're trying to go kill GLaDOS, but
the exact mechanics of how that happens
doesn't come together until fairly late.
Because you don't want to spend
a bunch of time integrating
your story and your levels without
having a bunch of confidence
that these levels are
actually good enough to ship.
Which we do have for
a bunch of the game,
but as new levels and new
mechanics are being introduced,
it all kind of goes haywire.
So it's just mostly a pretty
strong collaborative process
between the writers and
the designers and it all
goes back to the play testing.
AUDIENCE: Can you talk
a little bit about how
the sound interacts with
portals, like in 3-D positioning
of the audio sources?
DAVE KIRCHER: So the question was
how sound interacts with Portal.
And my memory's a little fuzzy.
I'm pretty sure we tried to
replicate a little bit using
just a simple-- basically the exact
same solution as with our lighting.
Where it's like we have a sample
point in front of a portal and we
have an emitter on the other side.
I can't remember if we shipped that way.
TEJEEV KOHLI: I think we did.
DAVE KIRCHER: Yeah.
TEJEEV KOHLI: I think there's a
microphone or in-game microphone
and an in-game speaker on
the portals on both sides.
So if you're on this side
of the portal, you'll
hear what's happening on the other side.
Pretty sure that's how we shipped.
DAVE KIRCHER: Yeah, but I don't
think we made any special concessions
to make it seem like it was going
through a tunnel or anything like that.
We just wanted to make sure you
could hear what was going on.
TEJEEV KOHLI: Not through
the portals specifically.
I know there was a bunch of stuff
we did for the tractor beam.
Like when you head to
the tractor beam, it
kind of fuzzles everything else around
you and muddles the sound a little bit.
But going through the
portals themselves,
I don't think there's anything
specific we did there.
At least not that I can--
it's been a long time.
DAVE KIRCHER: It's been a long time.
AUDIENCE: What were
examples of puzzle games
that inspired you when
you making your games?
TEJEEV KOHLI: Uh, Portal.
[LAUGHING]
The question was, what
puzzle games inspired us
when we were making our game?
DAVE KIRCHER: I can't think
of a strong inspiration.
I'm mostly a code guy, so I didn't do a
whole lot of the actual puzzle design.
But when I'm thinking back, we
didn't have a whole lot of sources
to draw on because it was a
fairly new concept in general.
I can't think of any sources I drew on.
I mean--
TEJEEV KOHLI: I wasn't
kidding when I said Portal.
When we were making Tag, I
think Portal had come out a year
or two earlier before that and
was really good and a big success.
And we were trying to
learn from how they were
teaching the players different things.
And that's one of the
biggest things we took away
in our student game was how do you
teach players different mechanics?
And I think Portal did a
really good job of that.
By teaching by doing
instead of by showing.
So like the players doing
all the stuff and then
figuring it out instead
of someone showing a video
or just telling the player, hey,
here's what do you do next, and then go
and doing that.
So we tried to take
that at heart, and as we
were doing in our game introducing
new paints and new mechanics,
doing it the same way where
we introduce them in a way
that the usage is obvious enough
that the player will try it out.
And when they try it out and it
works, they feel really good about it.
Because they feel like they figured it
out instead of us doing all the work
and showing them what to do.
So a lot of that kind of was a
specific thing that we took from Portal
and trying to do it in our game.
AUDIENCE: How many people did it take
to create these two games, Portal
and Portal 2, across the
different functional units--
development, writers, and the rest?
TEJEEV KOHLI: So the question
was about how many people
it took to make Portal and Portal 2.
Portal 1 was a pretty small
team for the most part.
DAVE KIRCHER: So Portal 2 started
as the seven people that worked on--
TEJEEV KOHLI: Portal 1.
DAVE KIRCHER: Yeah.
Sorry, Portal 1 started
with the seven people
that worked on Narbacular
Drop directly transplanted.
And then we started working
fairly early with two writers.
And we were leveraging
other people at Valve
to answer questions and help us
hit the ground running as far
as how to use the engine.
But it was mostly just those
nine people working day to day.
And then Portal 2 ballooned quite a bit.
TEJEEV KOHLI: Portal 2
was a much bigger team.
By the time I joined Valve in
2009, I think there was already
a pretty big Portal 2 team.
They already had a field
the mechanics figured out.
The game was pretty different from
what you see now, but at that point
it was already maybe 10, 12 people.
And then like it slowly increased.
Like we were four or five that
got hired for our paint game.
So we joined that team.
And then I think by the end
of it, there were probably
close to 40, 50 people working on it.
That was towards the very end because
we had to ship on two consoles and PC
and we had a whole co-op mechanic.
And there was a whole co-op
campaign be worked on separately
as well as a single player one.
So it was a pretty big
team by the end of it.
Much bigger than Portal 1.
And the game itself I think is
much bigger than Portal 1 as well.
I think the single player
campaign itself is probably
more than twice as long.
And the campaign-- the co-op
one is probably also that big.
DAVE KIRCHER: I remember in Portal 1 we
would have to do frequent integration
testing and I think I got my play time
on Portal 1 down to like 45 minutes
and Portal 2 is several hours.
TEJEEV KOHLI: Yeah.
So it's a much bigger game,
so it took a lot more people.
AUDIENCE: How does the game engine
that you used compare to Unity?
Is it more straight-up C
programming from scratch,
or is it a lot of the
drag-and-drop stuff you see?
TEJEEV KOHLI: So the question
is how did our game engine
compare to something like Unity.
For both Portal and
Portal 2, we used Source,
which is our in-house game engine.
And it's very different
from how Unity works.
So the way Unity works is
mostly like a really big editor.
Like what you're seeing in the
editor is the game essentially.
Like all the entities
and stuff are loaded.
Obviously more stuff
gets loaded at one time.
But what you're seeing
is what you're getting.
Whereas the way Source works is it's
got a bunch of these discrete tools that
make stuff.
So there's a level editor, which
is where you make your level.
And then you import that into the
game and you run the game separately.
And what you're seeing in a level
editor is not what you see in the game
because a lot of the entities and
stuff don't translate to the editor.
A lot of the lighting and
stuff has to be pre-baked.
Unity has some pre-baked
lighting as well.
But in the way it worked in Source--
Source I think is a combination
of a bunch of discrete tools
for each different aspect of the game.
So I get a separate particles
editor, separate model editor,
separate editor for VO and the face
poser, and the separate level editor.
And then there's a game engine that
takes the compiled versions of all--
compiled outputs of all those things
and then puts them in the game engine
and combines them together.
And then all the code is
pretty much exclusively C++.
I don't think there's
really anything else.
There might be a couple a
handful of things that are not,
but all the tools are C++.
All the game engine all the
runtime code is all C++.
Source 2 is a little bit different,
but still going forward on that front,
I'm not trying to do what Unity's doing.
Because Unity is more of
your running scripts--
C# scripts-- and then you're just
compiling them while the editor's going
and the rapid iteration and stuff.
Source doesn't really have
that same model of working.
But the advantage is
that we control all of it
and then the ceiling
for what we can produce
is theoretically quite a bit higher.
So there's tradeoffs to it.
And also we make all our tools
and all our engine stuff in-house
and we're the primary
customer for our games.
So we're not trying to
do what you Unity is
doing and trying to service to anyone
out there who wants to make anything.
And Unity has thousands of
people working on their engine
and we have quite a few
orders of magnitude less.
But I think we are aware of
all the tradeoffs we're making.
We're not trying not to
do what they're doing.
We're just seeing-- and we're
learning from them, too,
and Source 2 has taken a few cues
from stuff like Utility and stuff
like Unreal.
Trying to be more user friendly even to
our own customers, internal employees.
But it's not like--
the way of working is very
different between Source and Unity.
I think we're good.
All right, well, thanks
again for having us.
[APPLAUSE]
COLTON OGDEN: Thank you
all so much for coming.
So there's some extra pizza outside,
but that was Portal Problems.
So thank you very much.